the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is if it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
great well this is a special edition of
into the impossible the podcast of the
arthur c-- clark center for human
imagination which is a center at the
campus of UC san diego and the first
possibly only of its kind and certainly
we were one of the first podcast in the
university of california system very
proud of that and i'm especially proud
to be welcoming our special guest today
julian Guthrie who has not only been an
inspiring mentor to me as a writer has
helped me out with my writing and will
maybe get into her process a little bit
but she's also a friend and a huge
supporter of the mission which is really
to inspire people to the greatest human
potential that they have and that is
really one of the deepest missions both
of the Clark center of arthur c clarke
himself and of what we're trying to do
at the university of california here in
san diego so Jillian it's great pleasure
to have you here thank you so much for
coming back to San Diego as last time we
were together was about three or four
years ago I cannot believe how time has
flown and you look exactly the same I've
aged horribly but but the but it's been
fun and just phenomenal so we're having
you here on the occasion of the launch
of your which book is this this is my
fourth book Wow I'm fourth non-fiction
book that is incredible and my favorites
right same with children right so this
is called alpha girls the women upstarts
who took on Silicon Valley's male
culture and made the deals of a lifetime
and I think it what's so wonderful about
this book and I had a chance to read it
before it came out and really fell in
love with it and you know to be honest
with you when I first heard that you're
writing yet I thought if anyone could
write this book it's you but I was
curious how you went from this book
after pivoting to this book after having
written about the race to privatise
Space Flight and before that writing
about Larry Ellison and what inspired
you to write this book it's just such a
phenomenal change of pace for you so I
actually was inspired to write alpha
girls by my experience promoting how to
make a spaceship
and I would be out at events with Peter
Diamandis the extraordinary of course
founder of the XPrize and the really the
protagonist of how to make a spaceship
and I would see these you know there
would be crowds big and small and there
would be you know so few women and there
would be entrepreneurs and there would
be start-up folks and there would be
engineers and of course aerospace geeks
I say that fondly and I was like where
are all the women you know these are
such dynamic industries so to see this
disparity or this under-representation
what really got me thinking like why are
women not represented in equal numbers
or any level of parity in these dynamic
industries what does it mean so I
started thinking about it in that way
and then being a journalist in San
Francisco for so many years of course
Tech was my backyard so I wasn't a
Bolivia stew this factor of so few women
in tech but I thought it would be really
interesting to find a field kind of a
microcosm of this bigger issue and
really focus in and I zeroed in on
venture capital as this area where
really the people the venture
capitalists have this outsized influence
on how we all live shaping everything
from you know the way we communicate to
the cars we drive to the medical devices
we may one day need so then I started
finding who are the women 94% of all
venture capitalists who write the checks
who control the money are men but that
made me think well 6% then are women and
who are they and what does this world
look like to them and to tell their
stories so that's how I got into it yeah
and the fact that it took place you know
midst this technological milieu and
blowing through the valley at that time
in the 80s and 90s but what was so
striking to me and I know Peter
personally as a friend you know he I
feel like this book was more personal
than your previous book maybe maybe than
any of your books so far because you
really got to know the characters or the
reader
starts to get to know the characters and
I don't want to give I hate when podcast
you know I'll just give it aside to the
camera when interviewers said you know
can you tell us exactly what your entire
books about and the entire plot themes
and narratives and give away anything so
that my reader listeners don't have to
buy it so I don't give way too much but
it's it's it's at times you know
incredibly inspirational but you get so
deeply invested in them that I mean some
of it is tragic and and sad and I found
myself being emotional I mean how do you
dissociate kind of the different
characters that you got to meet and
they're also for women that are really
the main protagonists of this book how'd
you keep track of it all I mean with
Peter it's the single focus he's very
dynamic and each one of these women is
like a you know I want to say a female
Peter but they're they're each as
compelling if not more so so how did you
manage that well I felt that like with
how to make a spaceship while Peter
Diamandis is the main character and this
is nonfiction so I say character I mean
it he's true real person but I did have
great secondary characters with that I
had Burt Rutan I had Eric Lindbergh I
had Mike Melville I had Brian Benny so I
felt like I wrote many biographies on
each of those really incredible
individuals or how to make a spaceship
and this similar the billionaire and the
mechanic my book about Larry Ellison and
his quest for the America's Cup there I
had two principal figures from the book
Larry Ellison and the mechanic Norbert
Byron and so I went back and forth in
the structure of the book with that so
alpha girls was it was like writing for
biographies or helping them with for
memoirs really because it was so
personal and the structure of it is
chronological but it was really tricky
because they come onto the canvas of
Silicon Valley at different times
they're very different women with very
different backstories different
investment methodologies different
approaches and very different challenges
sometimes different betrayals that they
faced
so I set it up chronological alternating
from one woman's story to the next and
as you noted the stories got very
personal but I write in a novelistic way
so that I think with how to make a
spaceship you know you learned about
Peter Diamandis 'as you know triumphs
and his failures and the challenges and
you learned about the backstory of Burt
Rutan so that's always how that's my my
mo that's how I go about writing is to
understand who the people are they're
always very character-driven yes and
then cool technology in the background
yeah right gravitate to that underdog
stories with really cool technology that
unites and have an ultimately very
helpful message and culmination so when
you were constructing the book and
you're going through the research
process well I do want to get to your
actual process because you're incredibly
inspiring and and productive and I think
that to produce you know consistently
extremely high quality high interest and
appealing works is just an extremely
rare skill and it's led up to a movie
that we'll talk about
based on this book hopefully we'll get
to by the end but what were some of the
surprising things that you didn't maybe
expect along the way or when you first
started with the book proposal and you
made a pitch sort of maybe first to
yourself what was surprising and then
what may be surprised others along this
the process of making this book come to
come to life so vibrantly this book was
the biggest surprise to me the story was
the biggest surprise to me the research
was it really has changed the way I look
at the world I say that with all honesty
you know each book changed me and
brought something to me but this opened
my eyes in ways that I hadn't
anticipated
in particular the ridiculous barriers
that women face today have faced and how
persistent those barriers are and the
challenges that women face how women are
underrepresented at the top levels in so
many industries so that was a revelation
to me it feels like it's a call to
action I mean I'm a journalist I
didn't get into his into this as an
activist but I kind of walked out of it
with all of these issues and all of
these women and all of these struggles
and their successes that are very much a
part of me and so that was really
surprising it was it was it was also
surprising to see in a way these great
success stories because you don't hear
about them in Silicon Valley you hear
about how inhospitable Silicon Valley in
tech how those fields are or those how
that is to women and here are women who
love tech love venture capital love as
venture capitalists finding those
startups that potentially will become
something important something that will
make the world a better place that will
bring us something new mentoring the
entrepreneurs you know how they love
that despite the barriers despite the
hardships really love the industry and
figured out how to succeed in the
industry so that's also a story that
seldom really seldom told one thing that
surprised me and I was you know
confidentially now hopefully thousands
of people will watch this but when you
told me that the idea for the book and I
got a chance to read at first I was
worried you know hearing these kind of
which I took to be horror stories of
Sheryl Sandberg the reaction to her book
you know lean in and I thought she took
incredible heat and completely
undeservedly so it ended up making her
stronger and but I find you know
everything I'm seeing online and social
media and elsewhere people are just
reacting with such you know warmth to
this book and I wonder you know that was
pleasantly surprising to me because I
had last thing I wanted as one of my
friends well she doesn't and so that
surprised me I'm glad I didn't you know
maybe it didn't happen and so far it
didn't surprise you but well you know
worried about a backlash at any point to
these stories you know the whole
survivorship bias well these women made
it but most women don't so you know is
there was there ever concerned and
around those you know kind of parameters
for you I wasn't concerned about that
but the women themselves were definitely
concerned
about that you know the hardest thing
about this book was getting the women to
be really honest about their stories and
their shortcomings you know they could
talk all day about their successes
although even that women have held
themselves back and not been seekers of
the spotlight and have even shunned the
spotlight because they didn't want to
stand out as women because they were
trying to fit in with the guys but the
women had a very very difficult time
seeing the importance of telling the
complete picture and that is when they
were down when they were hurt when they
were sick when they were diagnosed with
cancer when they were getting a divorce
where did they make a mistake how were
they pulled back from there from the
glass ceiling maybe by someone closest
to them because unlike hidden figures
where you had these incredible women you
know helping to get John Glenn into
space women mathematicians you know that
was 50 years ago 50 plus years ago and
these women are working in the industry
today and it's still a male-dominated
industry so the women were had great
trepidation about their stories being
out there and being very honest and on
occasion naming names you know there are
a lot of good guys in the book and then
there's some guys who didn't behave so
well so there was fear more the the
women had fear I didn't so much although
I was on such a tight deadline that I
just had to think about the fear of not
finishing the book so there's a you know
very true trope in my opinion you know
the old joke you know how do you tell if
if an engineer is out going it's because
he looks at your shoes instead of his
when he talks to you anybody out there
I'm kind of like that myself but did you
note similarities I mean were these
women introverted the way that we think
of you know this guy exterior typical so
I mean some of them had a financial
background only some had a technical
background so I met both especially the
ones in the engineering side that came
more from that culture
what kind of commonalities did you know
with people like Ellison and and diamond
and the kind of male stereotypical you
know as I said introvert although those
guys are not now introverts but in the
past I think that they were well really
different models of success which is
another super interesting thing about
that contrasts this book to my prior
works that happened to be more
male-dominated and that is with like
Larry Ellison and with Peter Diamandis
certainly we Elan musk with some of the
other kind of titans of the industry who
have interviewed their success was more
kind of standing on the outside mmm not
backing down not particularly a
collaborative model creating something
out of nothing where it was fascinating
to me because the women who succeeded
and I can talk about their commonalities
but I just noticed a difference in how
how they succeeded in this
male-dominated industry they succeeded
really one incremental step at a time
but those small victories really added
up to something significant you know it
was as if they had to get in almost
through like Trojan horse analogy here
where they had to get their foot in the
door and they had to learn how to
perform they had to learn how to play by
the rules that were you know established
by others in this case men and they got
really good at that and they got so good
in fact that now they're kind of
rewriting those rules but it was more of
this what I now call an everyday radical
or there's a term a tempered radical
where you're affecting change as you go
you're but you're kind of rocking the
boat without being tossed overboard it
is exactly it's evolutionary I like the
way you put that in terms of what the
women had in common with each other and
with some of the male visionaries who
I've written about is first of all a
love of what they're doing and a passion
and certitude that they're in the right
field even if you're surrounded by
naysayers so they had that and then the
women just among themselves also had a
few things in common that were really
key to their success and that may sound
somewhat I don't know about trivial but
that were really really key tools they
used one was humor really using humor to
sometimes defuse tense situations with
the guys knowing when to take issue with
something and when to let it go like you
know an off-color joke do you take issue
with it or do you let it go so they were
brilliant at like knowing when to do
what and so there were commonalities
like that humor when to take issue with
something kind of eyes on the prize
mentality of you know keeping your sense
of what your goal is also specializing
these women really specialized in a
field and in investment opportunities so
you know for one it was cybersecurity
for one it was kind of Internet
infrastructure stuff making the internet
safer and faster so they each figured
out which is a great which is a great
lesson for women it's really you know
figure out a specialty make something
your own and sometimes they found that
being a woman in these you know like
Teresa Gow and cybersecurity she would
go to these conferences and an industry
events and she was the only woman in the
room and sometimes because she really
knew her stuff and she was a woman she
stood out and so it wasn't always a
disadvantage to you know being a woman
mm-hmm
allowed her to write to really be
portrayed and a cura light which is
which was beneficial to the companies
and the firms that were hiring them
which is which is ultimately I think one
of the biggest penalties for people that
do discriminate is it ends up being one
of the worst things that they can do for
their own cause and that's they had
or you know enlightened view they would
never do so in the beginning but
certainly they would you know I think it
would be a much kinder gentler culture
for everyone involved well there's also
the bottom-line financially that's right
companies that are more diverse in the
top management levels are also more
profitable so if you don't believe you
know if you don't believe in
diversifying you know as a moral or
ethical right imperative then you know
there's the bottom line that it that it
it's you know research shows that it's
you're more profitable the more diverse
you are in the top management level how
things change now besides the obvious
sort of new thing to me at least was the
sort of sisterhood that seems to emerge
and I don't give too much away but but
now there is this kind of you know
self-supporting and and and positive
feedback network that's been developed I
wonder you know if you had a daughter
that was you know getting ready a friend
or you know your sister whatever that
was thinking about going to the valley
and thinking about being in venture
capital I mean is it a place that you
would recommend have things changed
enough to be you know I mean hopefully
with the heralding of your book that you
know eyes have been open but is it a
place that is filled with toxic
masculinity is it really is it or is it
is it something that's fundamentally
different from what the struggles that
these four women faced I would
absolutely say it's a great place for
women both tech and venture capital I
mean I think it is exciting it is again
you're playing a role in shaping the
future your there's an element of
journalism to it where you're
parachuting into these different worlds
let's say you're hearing pitches on all
these different companies and you have
to become an expert in that very quickly
gather a lot of information assimilate
the information understand it pretty
readily make a decision on it in my case
write a story about it
but it's exciting you know
intellectually going into all of these
different fields dealing with
entrepreneurs who are generally great
optimists and dreamers and you hope very
technologically savvy and market savvy
as well so it's really exciting I don't
think there I don't think there is that
toxic masculinity I
think that was probably what happens is
there's this when there is this gender
imbalance there's a power dynamic that
is unhealthy very non toxic that has
been outed in so many different
industries and it certainly has been in
Silicon Valley but I think it's a great
place for women to work and I know a ton
of great guys who are also trying to
bring in more women to bring in more
diversity gender racial diversity as
well so it can't be a conversation you
know by her for her with her it has to
be a conversation between men and women
at the table and it has to be sincere
having said all that you know still to
this day when I started my reporting two
years ago is 94% of all investing
partners were men today it's 92 percent
so there's been an incremental gain but
that's still it's going in the right
direction what the worry is is that
there is this tokenism that oh we have
our one woman partner now now that the
spotlight is on this issue and so we can
check that box and you don't really
start to affect change with only one you
need at least two for a quorum and to
have any sort of institutional cultural
change
it requires that but the sisterhood is
fantastic and that's happening across
industries that I see whether in home
building or whether in advertising or
law or medicine or you know I don't know
if you what you see on this but
certainly in venture capital in tech
there's really great sisterhood
networking opportunities that just
didn't exist before and from your own
kind of insider's glimpse that you got
to see I mean it's not a major that we
offer here you know previous II you know
that's not very weaking it so it sounds
like you know to be if you're gonna be
advice to a woman or a man what sorts of
skill sets it sounds like being a
generalist and knowing a lot and be
having a diversity where you really want
to understand different aspects not only
focused on one narrow but you know but
very deep aspect of you
of your studies what advice would you
give to people men and women seeking
this field as a profession since it
isn't you know something you can just
take out of the course catalog be
entrepreneurial yourself it's ideal if
you have some technical skills specialty
MBA is three of the four of my main
alpha girls had MBAs one did not had an
electrical engineering degree but was
probably was of the four for sure the
most successful entrepreneur who also
helped Marc Benioff
found a kind of a big company called
salesforce.com
but just personality wise I think
inquisitive kind of insatiably curious
about the world about where we're going
voracious reader and an interest in
what's the next technology coming down
the pipeline a sense of globally trends
where are we what's next that's why I
think it's so dynamic I think it's a
really incredible field actually
expertise so because I'm selfish I want
to ask some questions for myself so I
want to know a little bit more if you
could explain a little bit more about
your process and how do you do all these
incredible projects that you're involved
with you have a set schedule do you work
only under deadlines so I get my idea
and then I write a proposal and then
that goes out and hopefully sells and
then I start in earnest although I do a
lot of research on the proposal stays
just to understand what the story is and
knowing that you have to live with it
for a couple of years so you and the fig
yeah and the characters so it has to
have longevity and for me I also want
books that stand the test of time in
terms of the messages and the people and
and then I am always I have this kind of
dream vision dream
where I'll actually do all my reporting
and finish my reporting and then I start
writing and it's like clean-cut like
that but that never happens
I'm always reporting as I'm writing even
up till the very very end and I don't
have I mean I spend more and more time
staring at that that screen that
formidable white screen yes
cursing cursing the cursor as the
deadline nears but I've been cranking
out you know I think I've had four books
in eight or nine years and it's pretty
grueling it's really fantastic to see it
start coming together people ask me if
it's fun it's fun learning learning is
fun but it's just it's it's I feel such
a sense of drive personal drive to do
better each time if that's possible and
I put that on myself and then just you
know sometimes it's just it's just time
you know it's time you have to you can't
it's it's you really have to concentrate
as you know having you've done this and
did this very success successfully takes
a lot from you but it's so rewarding
you'll have to tell me your favorite
moment but my favorite moment of the
whole process the best moment that makes
it all worthwhile is similar I suppose
to having a child where you get to hold
the book when I get that one copy or a
few copies delivered and it's like it
goes from this idea something I was just
carrying around in my mind and then I
start putting onto paper and then each
word adds up to something and then
you're holding a book and I peel you
know peel that FedEx open and I'm like
my book is here and that's to me it's
just like that's a perfect moment yeah I
always say you know it's the closest men
can ever get to win
we can't take the pain it what was your
favorite part I think for me it was a
combination of kind of gratification
certainly that moment getting it and
then showing it to my kids and my wife
that it actually existed but then having
people write to me say things like you
know my father told me you know unless I
were to win a Nobel Prize this young
lady told me I won't be a good scientist
and so it's not even worth trying to
become a scientist and I wish I had your
book ten years earlier because I would
have been a scientist you would have
inspired me to continue with it those
kind of things are really gratifying
yeah I mean you hope that there's
someone in the future you know I've
heard it said that you know most authors
will trade you know a hundred readers a
year from now for one reader a hundred
years from now so that kind of print you
know that attitude of longevity that you
spoke about which I think all of your
books you know hold within them I want
to finish up because we're gonna you're
going off to a big speech you're giving
here in front of more than a hundred
people at the UC San Diego's Medical
School of all places you'll be
surrounded by oh tech hopefully
hopefully we won't need much medical
assistance but word has it
that's your bank working on a film
adaptation or version of this of this
book of your most recent book alpha
girls can you tell us anything about it
or is the are these things top-secret no
no I can so alpha girls feels like a
different sort of book to me it feels
like it's a movement or part of a
movement feels bigger in a way like it's
far bigger than me than I am and it
feels like the momentum just continues
to grow so very exciting on adaptation
side so the book was a DAP is being
adapted for television for a multi
season series I have to get the lingo
down but I went with a woman who a woman
and she's one of three women in history
to have won an Academy Award as a
producer which is wrong only three women
in history her name is Kathy Schulman
she's extraordinary
she is an alpha girl she has lived this
this she's lived this story in her own
way
many women have it cuts across
industries but in Hollywood a woman
trying to make it again in this
male-dominated world and she's done so
so she got the story she gets the story
we'll have a big announcement with the
on the development side any day now
which I'm very excited about but it's
moving forward and talented screenwriter
is involved also a woman so it's it's
been fun introducing those women to to
the Alpha girls and seeing this this be
adapted for a different medium so it's
really an honor yeah and a lot of fun
yeah I mean it's all well deserve as you
said I think that's really the apt word
I mean I saw a picture of a senator and
presidential candidate Kirsten
Gillibrand holding a copy of your book
with a young young lady supporter of
hers and yours but it's true you started
a movement and that's pretty rare that
you get to start a movement in any field
but let alone one is competitive and as
and as sort of intense as writing and
and bringing together not only a work of
literature work of scholarship and
journalism but also to create passion
and have others share in that vision I
really commend you for that is such a
wonderful experience to get to know you
and have you here at UC San Diego
thank you I want to thank you again for
coming down here from the Bay Area and
we're really very much looking forward
to your talk and if it's not online by
the time you see this it will be posted
on the arthur c clarke center for human
imaginations website into the impossible
I'm Professor Brian Keating and this is
Gillian Guthrie and we thank you for for
tuning in today thank you
[Music]
the only thing they can be sure about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]